okay
all right let's start um
welcome welcome to the uh tdk seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless
you have questions if you have questions
you are welcome to a mute and ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q a session at the end
second today's ddps seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host mole tao who is
an associate professor in georgia tech
he received the bachelor's degree in
mathematics and physics in 2006 from
xinhua university
in china and phd in control and
dynamical systems
with a minor in physics in 2011 from
caltech
afterwards he worked as a postdoctoral
researcher in computing and mathematical
science at caltech from 2011 to 2012
and then as a current instructor at the
new york university from 2012 to 2014
from 2014 on
he has been working as an assistant and
an associate professor in school of
mathematics at georgia tech
he is a recipient of the wp
carey phd prize in applied mathematics
in 2011
american control conference best student
paper finalist finalist in 2013 the nsf
courier award in 2019
and um
a stats
past paper award in 2020 i triple e best
student paper finalist in 2021 and
coolant pack scholar award in 2021 22.
today molly will talk about trustworthy
learning of mechanical systems and
stifle optimizations with application to
transformer and optimal transport
which is a very interesting topic so
please
enjoy it and now without further ado let
me pass the button to molly by asking
one random question as usual today's
random question is
what is your favorite things to do other
than research mole you can answer that
and then continue your talk
thank you very much for the for the very
generous introduction um
so um
so i recently started uh twittering
because i was told that if you work on
machine learning you have to twitter
otherwise nobody knows your research oh
really and uh
i said well that's a joke uh but uh i
never i mean i'm not a very social
person so um i never used these and i
only have like you know
under 100 followers on twitter so i
guess you know it doesn't really matter
uh but i write on my twitter
that i'm actually a former um
uh semi a professional gamer
uh so i wish i still could have time to
to play games
that sounds fun okay thank you molly
is yours
yeah but anyway yeah thank you so much
again uh it's it's a great opportunity
for me uh it's i'm really happy to be
here and give this talk
uh so uh i thank uh the organizer uh dr
three uh for his kind imitation
so uh so my talk has a very long title
uh it doesn't really matter as i uh
explain um
so
the uh the key message that i want to
convey is that uh there are a lot of
interesting interactions between machine
learning and dynamics
that can be explored
so for example so if you go from the
left to the right direction
you can use machine learning to solve
dynamical problems in science and
engineering
if you go in the other direction
you can actually use dynamics to design
and analyze optimization sampling deep
learning algorithms
for example
for machine learning so of course you
know all these are very vague and broad
uh so
what i'll focus on is actually
geometrically structured dynamics in
this talk
and in particular in part one
i'll try to learn structured dynamics
from data
and
you and use what is learned to make
predictions to make predictions of the
of the system uh and i want to want to
do actually very long time prediction
and as you will see
the insurance of the structure is very
important as it allows us to to actually
have accuracy in a long time prediction
uh for the second part i'll focus on
optimization i'll optimize actually
functions that are defined on manifolds
uh using actually acceleration from
momentum
and uh and uh the work as you will see
will be actually um via structure
preserving dynamics in both continuous
and discrete time
i know that i mentioned other buzzwords
such as sampling or deep learning i will
not talk about them today
but but these are some of the things
that were actually very interested in
for example uh something is something
that we interpret in abrupt sense uh
including optimal transport generative
modeling
etc so uh so if any of you um
are willing to talk to me uh
after the talk i'll be very excited uh
similarly for deep learning so uh we
believe that dynamics can actually help
us gain a lot of good quali
quantitative understandings of deep
learning and even help improve deep
learning so uh so
i would be very excited to chat more uh
but uh but let me directly jump into uh
my first part which is uh
well so this sounds very scary but
really i'm i'm just going to be focusing
on special instances uh in which you use
machine learning to to actually
understand dynamics uh in sciences and
computing so uh in particular uh it'll
be based on a joint work with my my
former student jenny chen
which is on learning mechanical dynamics
from data
and
you can find this work published in a
machine learning conference icml is
available online
but but let me first explain why do i
want to predict the dynamics of
mechanical systems
it's because our world is actually
mechanical for example here is a planet
that is actually precessing around a
star
and imagine you are kepler or newton so
at your time
uh you didn't really know the underlying
governing equation that generates the
continuous trajectory all you have are
actually you know those those red dots
which correspond to observations of the
system at discrete time points and what
you want to do is you want to understand
the underlying governing equation they
underline governing physical law and
also make predictions such as the ones
given by the green dots
okay so this is this is really a long
time prediction um it sounds very
difficult and it is but but it's not
impossible because uh even though you
don't know like uh the the underlying uh
dynamics uh you know you have some
knowledge you know this is a mechanical
system it has structures
for instance oftentimes uh you have
conservation of energy of linear
momentum angular momentum etc and if you
dig deeper there is actually an
underlying geometric notion called
symplecticity
that is preserved by the dynamics
so what we want to do
is we actually want to build um we want
to hardwire this this conservation of
syntheticity in our learning model and
as a consequence as i will show we can
actually obtain superior prediction
accuracy because of that
so uh so the setup is is the standard
one so we have we have training data
which are multiple time series
i is is the index for discrete time j
indicates which sequence it is and uh
what we assume is that uh there is there
is a latent dynamics generated by uh by
a map phi so this file is like an
evolution map
it evolves uh the state at time time i
to time i plus one
and the goal therefore is very simple we
just want to learn the evolution map
from uh from the data and then the task
of forecast is trivial you just you just
have to iterate this map many times and
i want to emphasize that sometimes you
want to actually iterate really a lot of
times
and that's what i meant by long time
prediction
um
that sounds very natural but in fact
that's not what people uh do the most um
in the literature so traditional
approaches are more based on
differential equations
so uh so what is often assumed is that
there is an underlying latent dynamics
that evolves in continuous time that
generates a continuous trajectory
capital x and then what you see the data
is is really snapshot uh well the data
are snapshots of of the continuous
trajectory at discrete time points and
the goal there is to learn the vector
field f
but if you think about it f is different
from phi okay unless you know the the
the time interval between your data
points is infinitesimal but of course
you know in reality this is rarely the
case
if you if you
if you try to analyze this this
vector field based approach there are
several sources of inaccuracies
number one okay you are given really the
discrete time data so you have to use
them to approximate the time derivative
that's a numerical differentiation error
and then you have function approximation
error because you you want to
uh actually um
find the f that matches the time
derivative so you have function
approximation error
and then once you have found the
differential equation you have to
integrate it numerically to get the
future prediction so you have a
numerical integration error
if you use the map-based approach you
only have function approximation error
so so you you still have error in
approximating phi but that's it
in addition you can hardwire physics
into the learning model
uh and what do i mean by physics
so uh in this particular case i mean
symplecticity so i require uh this map
by the way this is syntheticity in
coordinates so i require this map to
have a jacobian
that satisfies this quadratic equation
for all spatial points
okay why do i want this art condition
uh it's actually a very intrinsic
uh it's it's basically like a signature
of mechanical systems for example if
there is a latent dynamics that is
hamiltonian then no matter what the
hamiltonian is uh the solution flow phi
is always going to be a sympathetic map
okay so that's why we actually want this
badly uh we want this to be a hard
constraint we want it to be satisfied
exactly we don't want any approximation
in this
so things like regularizers etc etc are
not considered
um so so therefore our goal is to find
the map phi that matches the training
data while satisfying this constraint
exactly
that's actually pretty challenging uh so
that's why we actually use fuzzy
mathematical tool to do it so um
so there is actually a deep theory
that says roughly speaking
there is a one-to-one correspondence
between a sympathetic map and something
called a generating function so uh
what do i mean by that okay so a simple
map evolves the current position and and
momentum to the future position and
momentum
authentic function on the other hand is
different it actually depends on a
mixture of present and future for
instance here is example an example
where s depends on the current position
and the future momentum
and then
you have to have equations that link the
the correct all four variables together
so in fact there is a system of of pdes
that this generating function has to
satisfy so basically uh you know all the
all the current position q and p
and and the future position q and
momentum p are matched through this pde
um so i don't think i have time to go
into the profound theory of huntington
jacobi which is behind this but uh but
at least you know in terms of what we
can do it's it's very clear
now uh we can just find a neural network
to parametrize this this function s
instead of this this evolution map phi
in order to match the training data
and therefore we call our resulting
method to be generating function neural
network to be a little more precise
you can use your favorite neural network
uh
yes so um
so syntheticity uh has good effects uh
that i'll actually explain in a moment
so i'm answering a question that was
typed in the chat basically by gaining
syntheticity uh by ensuring exact
syntacticity i can get uh
superior long time performance superior
long time accuracy of
of my prediction so that's a great
question thank you so much uh you will
see a quantitative version very soon
um
so uh so coming back to to to the
formulation so um
so you can use any of your favorite
neural network you know feed forward
resnet or anything fancier uh to
parameterize uh this as function so you
know there's an underlying ad function
you don't know what it is so you're
looking for an approximation to it you
use a neural network to do it and then
you require your neural network to uh to
nearly satisfy these pdes so you can
therefore you know come up with an
objective function which is the the
residual of the of the equations and
then minimize the parametrization of the
neural network
okay so that's that's what you do for
the training
and then you never have to worry about
syntheticity depending on the neural
network you know your s may be
your sd card may be a very good
approximation of class it could be a
very bad approximation if you use a very
small neural network but architecture
you don't train it
um
yes yes the idea is not limited to
neural network at all uh so uh so
anything that can give you good function
approximation will work um
but the the
but my point is that you don't have to
worry about syntacticity at all so you
can get a very lousy approximation of s
but you still get it get an exactly
synthetic map
okay so because we are using a map based
approach and also we have exact
syntacticity uh we can actually use some
of the fancy tools from dynamical system
uh called km theory uh we can we can
actually construct some theoretical uh
framework uh which enables us to prove
under reasonable conditions
uh that you have a bound of the
prediction error so uh so in this bound
you know these two are the predictions
uh so n is a number of steps of
prediction and uh these two are actually
the truth so you don't really know them
but you know they exist they exist
because there's an underlying latent
dynamics what is this this this apps you
know in the error bound so uh it's
something that can be made arbitrarily
small it's basically the function the
approximation error of your neural
network so neural networks are
universal function approximators so so
theoretically you can make this
arbitrarily small if you try hard enough
the arguably most important part of this
result is is this one
so n is a number of predictions but
prediction steps h is the time step so n
times h is actually the physical time of
prediction
and n here can actually go very big
and uh and you see that the prediction
time actually appears as a linear term
uh on the inside the bound so this is
saying that the long time prediction
error is actually linearly growing with
the prediction time this is a pretty
long trivia because if you compare it to
traditional approaches
um
the lifetime prediction error can be
actually exponentially growing and this
is not because you have a bad bound uh
this this exponential error can actually
be attained
and this is really the consequence of
having exact simplexity
so
i i don't i don't um have the capability
of of talking about the
the km part of the which is uh
theoretical uh theoretically um
non-trivial uh but you need exact
syntheticity in order to have linear
growth
um and that's why when we try the method
for example the prediction of planet
orbits
our method has era
that are
at the very bottom when compared to some
of the other popular approaches
available
here is another example uh where
i try to learn something called the
standard map uh which is actually a
mechanical system that is chaotic
uh
if if you haven't heard of it before uh
it doesn't matter the the key point is
that it's a chaotic system and uh it can
be visualized by something called called
pancake pancake map uh which is the one
shown here
uh i don't know if my cursor can be seen
but
so basically here
you have those white regions which are
called stable islands and they are
separated by chaotic seas and you want
to capture
you know the structures of those stable
islands and our method namely gfn is the
only one that can capture the the major
uh stable islands um but of course you
know it's it's it's it's not perfect
either so there are still a lot of
things that can be done in the in the
future uh but but still you know uh it
has better performance uh than other
approaches
so uh so that's why uh our method uh
possibly has good applicabilities um
even to to chaotic systems as well
so let me quickly summarize by using a
map based approach
um
we can actually uh evolve the the tool
of generative function and develop a
generating function neural network that
gives you exact syntheticity of the
prediction
and because we have a map based approach
exact syntacticity and also generating
function
we actually managed to uh to revamp the
classical km theory uh to develop a
theory of km type for generating
function and this theory allows us to
actually prove
superior long-time performance uh
superior long-time prediction accuracy
of our method and uh and that's why we
say the method is trustworthy because we
know we have actually an error about
which is pretty good
okay so uh so i
like i'd like to pause for a second
because this finishes my first apart uh
if there's anything that i can clarify
please please don't hesitate
um there is a question
question in chat room uh from thailand
oh actually i had the same questions uh
she asked the previous slides is the
simplicity uh
sympathetic uh simplicity minimization
exactly and symplecticity uh the
minimization exactly and first if the
minimization does not reach the minimum
for example it's not zero then it will
not be exactly synthetic
right i mean the previous one not this
one previous oh you mean the the other
work
uh
the there is a the minimization um yes
slide yeah that one the
bottom
right so uh so it doesn't it doesn't
matter what the value
uh of of this objective function is
so even if you don't train uh as long as
you use generating function
uh you know you give me any s there is a
corresponding sympathetic map
and this map uh you know gives the
evolution uh
so so you you always have symplecticity
yeah but the thing is ass should satisfy
that right inside you know that ode or
pde
if that would that pde is not exactly
satisfied if this minimization does not
reach zero right
ah okay i see so yeah so for example if
you if if you think your data comes from
a mechanical system but it doesn't uh
then yes this this will not reach zero
um
but uh but but i would
there's
uh there is not much i can do i think
it's it's more like like a modeling
issue rather than a methodology issue
so
yeah so if it does not reach zero then s
is not exactly satisfying that pde or od
therefore the sympathetic math
no no that doesn't matter
thanks for the great question uh
but uh uh but as doesn't
s doesn't satisfy the pde for the data
but as actually generates something else
so so s
uh has a corresponding phi and and and
the trajectory generated by five will be
exactly satisfying uh the pde
so so so as we give a different
prediction
uh from the data uh so that that that's
for sure but uh but that still
corresponds to uh the evolution of a
sympathetic map um
it's it's just that you know um if
you're not if you're not trying very
hard to match the data
you will not match the data
okay so there's another question from
pat he asked what is
kam again just a highlighter oh yeah
yeah thank you thank you uh sorry sorry
i was trying to rush rush through things
uh uh kms is the the the initial of
three great mathematicians uh comograph
arnold and and moser uh so it's
basically a theory that says that okay
so if you have some mechanical system
that is good
uh if you perturb the system a little
bit um
uh
what will happen to your evolution after
a very long time
roughly speaking that's that's what km
theory is about so so in this case you
can see why it is being used because um
you know you have some underlying
mechanical system and then you
as you predict it you you make errors at
each step and and and you want to know
you know your prediction which is
another mechanical system due to
synchronicity um
uh you want to know how this new system
uh actually evolves how far it will
deviate from the original the the latent
mechanical system so that's that's why
km theory uh is is a major key uh in
doing the error proof
another question
from they are
are there similar long-term stability
guarantees for first order systems
ah okay thank you uh yeah i'm so glad to
hear from so many experts so um so it
depends on what kind of first order
assistance um one can have uh so um
so um there is something called
reversible system
that has a similar long-time error
analysis
as
um
so i think it really depends on the
structure um
but but of course you know there are
also systems uh in which you you you
know uh
things will you know linear growth of
era
will not happen for example you know um
you you can write fluid um as first
order systems but you know you can even
develop shock in finite time uh
so if you perturb the system a little
bit you know you get very different
behavior you can have um also chaotic
dynamics in which uh you know uh one
perturbation will get uh exponentially
amplified along with time um
so
um
it's complicated but there you don't
you may not necessarily look at uh
accuracy of a single trajectory but the
statistics of of a lot of trajectories
so uh
so then you know you have to do
something else
um i i hope i'm answering all those
questions but which which i i found to
be all very great ones
i think it's good enough for now i i
guess you can move on
okay thank you
thank you oh okay so let me go to the
second part so in the second part i want
to do the other direction which is to
use structured dynamics to do to design
machine learning algorithms and in
particular i'll talk about a joint work
with my student link hi cone itching
wang
and and the work was very recent um it's
basically on how to optimize a function
um
uh defined on a manifold called stiffer
manifold uh in a very fast fashion so
that's that's what this this word
momentum is about
you will see momentum basically uh helps
accelerating the optimization
if you have
by any chance heard me talking about
lead group optimization in the past
it's actually going to be different
because stifle manifold in general has
no group structure so um
so in some sense it's a generalization
of the of the prior work
so what is a stiffer manifold
it's it's a collection of matrices
importantly not necessarily square okay
so it's n by m
n is always greater or equal to m so
think about tall matrices
and the the those matrices have to
satisfy an orthogonality constraint to
be on this default manifold
more precisely you know you have n by m
matrix uh as an element of of of
of this set and in order to to qualify
uh you have to basically have also
normal columns okay so each column has
to be orthogonal to all the other
columns and also each one has to
normalize to
each one has to have a a two norm of one
that that's what really at this
orthogonal orthotic constraint is about
and of course there's a special case
when m is equal to n uh you do have a a
group structure so this this uh this
case degenerates two to what is known as
the orthogonal group
but in general you don't have any group
structure
why do you care about optimization on
stifle manifold for example okay let's
do a warm up exercise very simple but
but actually very important in data
sciences and even in traditional
sciences and engineering so
it's called the leading eigenvalue
problem so given an n-by-n matrix a you
want to find the largest m eigenvalues
of the matrix
and this is a non-trivial problem if n
is very big say a billion
and m is very small say 10.
um
one way to do it is to actually cast it
as an optimization problem okay so you
look for basically a collection of
orthonormal bases in n dimension but you
only look for m of them okay so so they
actually form a member of this default
manifold and then you you look or you
project this matrix a onto this subspace
spanned by those bases
and then you uh you you maximize
well you compute the sum of eigenvalues
of the projection and of course you know
that's given one subspace but because
you look for the largest and eigenvalues
you maximize the sum you look for the
subspace that maximizes the sum
okay so that's why this can be
formulated as an optimization problem
which is nice if m is small because you
know you you're basically not touching
the other irrelevant eigenvectors which
which are abundant
but of course you know you see also you
have to do this default optimization
problem uh and you need to do it exactly
on the manifold because you don't want
to mess up with the orthonormal basis
okay so uh so that's one motivating
example and of course some people may
say okay this is nice it seems pretty
general but it seems also pretty simple
because the objective function
is a quadratic function of x well
one thing that i want to say is that
quadratic doesn't being easy because of
the geometric constraint this is
actually a non-complex problem uh but if
you want harder problem uh here you go
so um so a second example uh it's called
projection velocity projection that
washes that distance
so what is trying to what is the thing
that we try to do here so we are trying
to to compute the similarity between two
probability measures so suppose you have
two probability measures
mu and mu
and they are actually probability
measures on a very high dimensional
space
you want to compute the distance between
the two measures of course a lot of
existing notions
are already very powerful for example
washer stem distance
washer stain distance is defined as
follows
as the following so you consider
basically all possible couplings between
the probability measures what does a
coupling mean a coupling is basically a
joint distribution uh such that its x
marginal is mu and its y marginal is new
okay so you
you optimize over all the possible
couplings you you look for the best
coupling such that you minimize
some cost
what is what is this cost uh it's called
earth mover distance roughly speaking
okay so you're trying to move
probability mass of x of mu
given by x to probability
mass of mu given at location y you try
to move those those earth
and of course you don't want to to move
too far you want to minimize the
distance of travel so so that's the
meaning roughly speaking the meaning of
of of this cost function
and then you get washes that distance
it's extremely powerful uh but uh but
it's also very costly to compute
especially if you have a high
dimensional situation
a lot of efforts have been made um to to
do some approximation of this
computation and uh and in particular you
know a collection of experts proposed uh
one solution is which is called
projection robust washington distance so
the idea is the following so maybe your
probability measure or data that
represents the probability measures
actually have low dimensional structure
and suppose you already know the low
dimensional structure say you have a low
dimensional subspace represented by some
orthonormal basis u
and then what you can do is you can
compute a vertical stand distance
between
projected m dimensional distributions
okay so you project the original n
dimension uh to m dimension
and if m is very small this is more
manageable but of course you don't
really know what this subspace is so you
have to actually look for it so you have
to do an altered maximization
that looks for the best uh best subspace
so this is computationally more
manageable like i said if m is much
smaller and also uh they have shown that
this is this is very robust for example
okay so if your data really have a low
dimensional structures and then it also
has some outliers after you do this this
projection and look for the projection
the outliers don't matter okay so this
allows you to focus on the essential
component of the of the data which which
has arguably a low dimensional structure
but you see okay this is also a stifle
optimization problem
and you again need to do this exactly on
the manifold you don't want regularizers
uh you want to you want to be exact
otherwise uh you mess up the the basis
uh the last example is something that we
are very excited about uh because you
know we sort of invented
so it's about making transformer which
is a very cool machine learning
architecture uh
even more
even better uh so in a nutshell
transformer is a recent but extremely
powerful machine learning uh deep
learning architecture and
it was first invented for for natural
language processing because it basically
handles uh sequences but for now uh it
percolates into other downstream
applications such as computer visions
and uh it basically has an infinite
reference window and that's why it's
it's powerful it's better than recurrent
neural network which has a short
reference window uh things like lstn for
example
were invented
to increase the reference window
but it's still not infinite but
attention the mechanism which
transformer uses actually has an
infinite type window
and by the way i got those nice
illustrations from michael fine uh
well his blog so so i'm very thankful
it's very clear um
and uh transformer actually does uh does
this infinite reference window by
something called attention layer
or more precisely multi-headed attention
layer uh and attention layer basically
um
tries to characterize
interactions between words
uh in a sentence and the interactions
can be actually long range
okay so so it's just just like this
and uh mathematically uh what happens is
it uh you know this attention layer has
things called attention heads
uh each attention head has trainable
parameters which are weight matrices
like this
and even though people are still trying
to understand transformer roughly
speaking those weight matrices
characterize interactions between words
and of course there's no unique way
english words actually interact with
each other
so that's why they actually use the
multiple attention hats to incorporate
different ways in which words actually
interact
and of course you don't know these
interactions apra so you have you have
to learn them that's why you have to
train you you have to train the model
you have to find uh those w's from the
training data
um
but then we ask ourselves okay so if
those w's actually characterize
correlations between words
uh why don't we make it orthogonal you
know this way maybe we can make the the
attain we're not wasting attention maybe
we can make the attention mechanism more
efficient more effective
okay so we tried this
and and if you think about it there is
actually um no unique way in which we
can we we can impose our functionality
way one
you take each head each hand has this w
i q and w i k
you can require each one of the two
matrices to be orthogonal so so you
require it to be to be on a stiffer
manifold and when you train you require
you know those those trainable variables
to stay on on the stifle manifold
uh way too you can require a
functionality across all heads
which means mathematically you have to
concatenate all those weight matrices
across all heads and then you have a
bigger matrix and you require it to stay
on a bigger stiffer manifold
we tried both we tried both on something
very popular called vision transformer
which applies transformer to to computer
vision to uh to basically image
classifications and more uh we train the
model from scratch and we test it on
standard um test data sets uh such as c5
10 and 100.
and we found
if you require a functionality within
each hat namely way one you get better
performance than orthogonality of
crosshairs
but that's still much better performance
than if you just do the vanilla version
so so training in euclidean space
requiring no functionality
in fact you know if you just impose a
simple orthogonality constraint to the
original vanilla version of visual
transformer you can get much better
performance than the euclidean version
and you can even beat
later improvements fancier models
simply just by doing nothing but
orthogonality
but there's a catch the catches
only if you train these models by our
optimizers there are existing optimizers
for example you know you can you can do
it very well if you don't incorporate
momentum but you actually get results
that may be even worse than the original
uh vision transformer
so our optimizer is actually doing
something
but anyway so that's a very long
motivation so hopefully you are
convinced uh why we want to do this
abstract uh non-trivial problem of
optimization on steeple manifold
the rest is how do we do it
so we actually use a variational
approach uh because it's going to be now
friendly to know euclidean spaces and it
naturally introduces a
very important notion of momentum
what is momentum uh it really originates
from mechanics and of course
you cannot avoid newton if you want to
talk about mechanics so newton said
uh the rate of change in momentum is
given by the force
uh it's very simple but it's
it's it's almost you know
half of the explanations of how our
world actually um
operates
um
so momentum therefore is given by
basically you know velocity uh so the
time derivative of position q times uh
mass
sorry i
i missed uh
the message and i
i don't know how to use webex um
um yeah yeah okay okay so if you want to
answer that the shouting and uh asked
how much better is the orthogonal uh
transformer better than vanilla
transformer yeah so okay so great
question so um
so we can
improve uh their prediction era by about
1.5 percent
and uh uh the fancy model improves
vanilla transformer uh vanilla vision
transformer by about about 0.3 percent
okay so uh so point three versus point
one uh we think it's a it's a
significant improvement but but there
are a lot of technicalities uh so i'll
i'll try to talk about these um
momentarily but that's that's of course
a very very very important question
thank you
um
okay so um
so yeah so okay so so so therefore this
is just a
system of odes that models newton's
newton's secret newton's law um
but then lagrange came along now graphs
oh i forgot to mention sorry
so here uh
p dot is of course given by the force
and we are considering a conservative
situation where f the objective function
is going to be the potential so uh so
that's that's why you know i have the
force being given by the negative
gradient of the of the potential
uh i'll come back to this
um and then lagrange came along lagrange
said okay there is an equivalent
variation of principle in which you
actually first define an action
functional uh s uh it's a functional
because it's a function of functions so
it's it's mouthful but uh but s is a
function of actually trajectory
uh so q is a trajectory
uh in position space
and this action functional is defined as
the integral
of lagrangian evaluated along the
trajectory and if you define the
lagrangian to be kinetic energy minus
the potential energy and then you you do
the first variation meaning you look for
the critical point of this functional
and then you see the corresponding euler
lagrange equation is exactly the same as
newton's equation
okay so this is the equivalent but
deeper formulation of newton mechanics
how is it relevant to optimization so
far there's no relevance because the
lagrangian is actually independent of
time explicitly so there is a time
translation symmetry and therefore
there's a conservation law uh the total
energy of the system namely kinetic
energy plus the potential energy is a
constant it's independent of time so if
you let the dynamics go you will see a
constant exchange between the kinetic
energy and the potential energy f is
never going to be minimized
but that is really because you have time
translation symmetry
so
if you break the symmetry if you make l
to be time dependent explicitly then you
no longer have conservation of energy
so
in a beautiful paper by bibi sono wilson
and jordan uh they introduced an
explicit way um
which is to multiply the origin
lagrangian by a time dependent explicit
function and then you can write down the
corresponding order lagrange equation uh
if you like you can rewrite it as a
first order system and p again changes
according to a net force but it's no
longer just this conservative force
there's an additional frictional force
due to this time
due to this time dependence
and this frictional force basically
removes the energy from the system and
you can actually prove that as t goes to
infinity the q the position variable
actually converges to a local minimizer
for sure so that's why this dynamics is
actually an optimization dynamics now
and it's closely related to optimization
algorithms in fact and that's why you
know this this paper is it's a uh
it's a foundational seminar work um
uh oh well i mean it
it also has the it's based on previous
work as well uh but
let me let me skip all the details uh so
if you choose r uh such that gamma is
three over t
you have some ode if you if you choose a
particular discretization of the ode you
actually recover a classical
optimization method called nesterof
accelerated gradient for convex
functions
if you choose gamma to be to be a
constant
one discretization gives you another
optimization method called nesterof
accelerated gradient for strongly
complex functions
and if you discretize things in a
different way you can recover something
called heavy ball which is also very
popular and all these should be
contrasted with gradient descent which
is a forward euler discretization of
gradient flow dynamics
and there no momentum is being used and
that makes a difference
in fact you know let's take an agc
for the example where c stands for
convex okay so if f is convex you can
prove that agc converges like 1 over k
squared where k is the number of
iterations whereas gradient descent only
converges like one over k so that's you
see you know this is a faster much
faster convergence and that's why people
say well that's one of the reasons that
people say momentum gives you
acceleration so that's why we want
momentum we actually want everything uh
for re for optimization of remaining
manifold
and uh this is actually pretty hard this
is very non-trivial and that's why we
act well especially if you if you want
to directly work with the ode or the
discrete algorithm that's very hard
that's why we actually dig deeper we
start with the variational principle but
before i describe how to do it
let me
let me first comment um you know give
give you a very quick illustration of
why remaining optimization is not review
so let's say um suppose you also want to
do something similar to before namely
you want to use gradient to do the
optimization so if you if you are if you
know uh optimization this is called
first order method um
first order information
f um
and then you should ask yourself what do
you mean by a gradient
for example so if g is a two by two
orthogonal matrix so this is a manifold
and uh let's take a tour example where
the objective function is the
determinant
and then you may say oh then well i'm
pretty sure you won't say but some
careless person will say okay the
determinant is easy to compute and then
you collect all the partial derivatives
and there you go you form the gradient
that's going to be wrong because um
orthogonal matrices actually have
constant determinant okay so the
determinant is either plus one or or
minus one and it's actually a constant
of each
connected component of the manifold so
the gradient is actually zero
so what's what's wrong the reason is
because the manifold is actually
one-dimensional in this case it's not
four-dimensional abcds are not
independent you cannot just just do
partial
derivatives okay so hopefully this shows
just the tip of the iceberg of why
manifold optimization is is uh is a deep
field
uh i'm always very nervous because i'm
afraid that i that i miss important
contributions um so let me know if i do
but but it's relatively safe to say that
if you don't care about momentum if you
just want to do gradient descent
manifold
this is very well studied
um what's new here is we have an
intrinsic way of adding momentum and as
a consequence we get an algorithm that
is very fast and very accurate
uh
so like i said the variational principle
is a rescue uh so
euclidean space uses this variational
principle uh
what about manifold so a pure
mathematician would say oh that's
trivial because you know uh so you still
have trajectory it's just a trajectory
it's moving on the manifold and for that
reason by the way i replace q by g it's
still a function of time but it's moving
on the manifold
and then g dot is in the tangent space
and uh and if you have a romanian
manifold uh you have an inner product
structure in the tension space so you
can just replace the previous kinetic
energy by a an inner product in the
tangent space and then you have your
lagrangian you can do the uh the
variational principle yes so in theory
this will work
you will get euler lagrange equation
that are still otes which correspond to
optimization dynamics
in practice the odes are pretty terrible
they are not very explicit and uh if you
want to further discretize the ode in
order to get an algorithm that's going
to be a nightmare
so you have to do something smart
in
one of our work uh we had a solution
when g is is a group
uh so when g is a group you can do
something like you know you you don't
want to deal with g dot because it's in
a tangent space which is changing as g
moves so you can pull everything back to
something called li algebra and this is
done by some fancy you know abstract
nonsense called reduction while
trivialization
uh very few people care i will not talk
about it it's not applicable here uh
because
now we care about stifle manifold as
default manifold is not a group
so what do we do we we do something else
so we have to we we revised the original
variation principle we use something new
called a constrained variation principle
so what is the original variation
principle so you have this lagrangian
you want the first variation of its
integral to be zero so that seems to be
very innocent but in fact a lot of
details are under the block the the
details uh the what matters is that okay
so when you do the first variation you
have to vary basically x in a function
space and this function space looks
complicated okay x is a function of time
and each time x is actually on this
default manifold and x dot is actually
on the tangent space so this function
space is highly nonlinear it's it's very
very hard to do the first variation
so we do something else
we introduce a function the ground
multiplier this this lambda is a
function of t and then the at each time
t it basically tries to enforce this
this constraint of of steeple
we add this functional ground multiplier
to the original lagrangian and we do
first the variation very importantly in
unconstraint flat function space okay so
x now is no longer constrained uh it's
still a function of time but at each
time it's just n by m n by n matrix
and lambda is n by n matrix uh it's a
lagrange multiplier so you can do this
without worrying too much about the
geometry uh let's do a non-trivial
because of you know this addition
additional variable lambda
but uh we have actually technology to
actually compute it out
so this is funny because this technology
was
was developed by us for for completely
different application uh in astronomy
but anyway uh we can actually get this
lambda and by the end of the day we can
get explicit ode in euclidean space
without
worrying about this lambda at all so i
need to be more concrete by this and in
fact this euclidean space is very
important so let me be more concrete
so
we can really get explicit ode for all
possible remaining
metrics but for concreteness let's
choose a metric tensor and then the
lagrangian becomes something like this
so you don't really have to worry about
the geometry anymore uh you know you
just have nonlinearity if you like and
and the magic tensor has a parameter a
and it can be anything in our setup so
you may think this is restricted anyway
because i specified the magic tensor but
in fact the literature only considered
that
a equals to zero or a equals to a half
so the literature is even more
restricted than us
and if you use this metric tensor you
can you can obtain optimization ode
which looks like this it's very
complicated you don't have to stare at
it i'll explain the key details so x is
the variable that you want to optimize
it changes in time as time progresses x
will become better and better
q is the the momentum the associated
momentum variable q changes according to
something very complicated
but
what matters is number one here what you
use is actually the euclidean derivative
it's basically the bad derivative that i
mentioned earlier uh but you can no you
don't have to worry about the geometry
you just take all the partial
derivatives and plug it in here and and
also here and here
the dynamics will take care of the of
the geometry for you um and in fact you
don't have to even think about stiffer
manifold anymore for now because
everything is actually done in euclidean
space x is just an n by n matrix and so
is q
uh but if you evolve this dynamics it
automatically does the geometry for you
because x and q will stay exactly on the
manifold
what that means concretely is x has to
satisfy this orthogonal constraint for
all time
q has to satisfy this equation which is
basically requiring q
to be in the tangent space
and this dynamics is automatically
guaranteed to converge to a local
minimum of f
okay so uh so depending on your taste
you may think this is great or this is
nothing because you know this is so far
just the imagination of a pure
mathematician uh it's not an algorithm
so we have to discretize the time of
this dynamics to get an optimization
algorithm
um
what we want is number one
after the time discrimination we have to
stay exactly on the manifold meaning
that i have to satisfy the previously
two constraints which is non-trivial for
example if you use euler or yoga kuta or
anything that is off the shelf it's not
going to be be working
but moreover we want the methods to be
explicit um
and in fact as efficient as possible for
example x is n by m n is big m is small
so we want iteration complexity uh that
you know computational complexity that
depends on m as much as possible but as
little on n as possible okay we don't
want n
and also you know if you if you know
remaining optimization you know people
oftentimes have to do exponential map
okay so you take the derivative you do
this exponential map so that you can
stay on the manifold and in our case the
exponential map is just the matrix
exponential we don't want to do it
either people sometimes use something
called kelly transform as an
approximation we don't want to do it
either because these things are great
but they are computationally very
expensive we don't want to do this
either
this is a highly non-trivial problem
for the sake of time
let me
let me skip all the details but
basically
we have methods that can satisfy all
those requirements um
and uh um
you can read the paper for details we
can talk also offline uh and the method
can be extended to adaptive learning
rate so we have an add-on a stifle
stifle version for adam as well okay so
that's that's our method and we tried it
on a transformer
so if we
so i guess um
people are leaving so how much time
um i have left yeah yeah well i'm just
please don't worry about the time
constraints i mean it's recording so
they can come back and then oh okay so i
mean take your time because i want to
have more discussions rather than just
just me be
speaking talking and talking so
let me be brief um so okay so uh so
there are a lot clearly a lot of
information in this table but basically
remember we have two types of
constraints that we proposed either we
can have orthogonality across all heads
or all heads of the attention
or we can have authority only within
each head so we have two big classes and
in each big class we have two smaller
classes uh either you can do stochastic
gradient descent or you can do add-on
which is adaptive learning rate version
so
blue indicates the best within each each
one of the four subclasses
and the underscore means the best
across all classes
this green
uh class is the baseline it's the
vanilla vision transformer um
and also the last class is improved
model a fancier model um that improves
the palm vision transformer
and um
and you see number one okay so if you
have orthogonality uh within each head
you get an
error which is like 8.3 percent
which is better than eight point eight
percent if you have optimality across
all heads
uh but even that is still much better
than nine point seven percent error um
if you if you don't do any authority
constraint
and uh you see okay so you have about
one point four percent improvement over
the trip the the the vanilla version
and that so that's that's a significant
improvement because you know we have to
to be in the context so if you use the
later fancier model for example uh you
know this one you can get nine point
about nine point five percent uh era so
that's already better than the the
original one uh that's better than um
than the original one by about uh three
point three percent but we actually get
more than one percent
so uh so we don't have to do anything
just impose a functionality uh and then
we can get further improvement
and uh and also important to note is
that you get those improvements only if
you train by our optimizers
for example you know here is a very good
method um but it doesn't have momentum
okay so if you use this momentum list
method you only get
uh you know 12.9 error so it's even
worse than the original version so so
optimizers do matter a lot
uh let me skip the robust projection
robust versus the distance example
as well as the simple leading eigenvalue
problem
maybe okay let me still say something
about this so remember this problem is
that given an n by n matrix a you want
to find its top and eigen values and
it's non trivial if n is very big and m
is small
and that's why we formulate it as an
optimization problem so
this is a problem simple enough that we
can do a lot of tests so
convergence for example our method is
the one at the very bottom it converges
the fastest uh manifold preservation we
get you know manifold preservation up to
machine precision uh what is interesting
are um also these two plots uh what are
they they are basically uh you know
validating our theoretical claim about
the per iteration computational
complexity
so our computational complexity per
iteration is n times n squared
and this is better than many existing
methods with momentum which is n squared
times m okay so so n is much larger than
m so therefore you know the above one is
much better um
the right plot is is something that
fixes in and
sorry fixes m that only changes and and
you can see you know uh uh existing
methods has this quadratic growth of
computational complexity computational
time within but always has has you know
linear growth within which is you know
the best you can hope for um and on the
left if you fix the ratio of n over m
and you increase either one of them you
see you know all methods increase
cubically
so that's the the sum remark about the
computational complexity but let me
summarize okay so we uh we do momentum
accelerated optimization or manifold
using variational principle uh the
original one is too complicated so we
have actually some revision which is
constrained variation of principle and
with that we can obtain
actually optimization dynamics in
continuous time uh
uh actually euclidean space so so you
don't really have to worry about
manifold at this stage even though the
dynamics actually stays exactly on the
manifold
and then
we have to discretize and this is where
you have to be very very careful because
you want to exactly preserve the
manifold and we managed to do so and as
a consequence we get very accurate and
efficient gradient descent method
accelerated by momentum for for stiffer
manifold
some applications include you know uh
you can actually make a tension
mechanism to be suitably orthogonal and
you can get significant improvement of
vision transformer uh you can also make
the notion of a very powerful notion of
projecting robust washes that distance
uh even better
so uh so i think i should stop here
thank you so much for your attention and
feedback thank you thank you molly for
the wonderful talk there's a
one question you haven't answered it was
from the harsh he asked how is adding
time dependent in lagrangian different
from adding a
dissipation time via lagrangian
the lambert principle
yeah yeah thank you great great question
so
um
so you can you can actually um
do delam bell uh principle um
as well you can add a delam term
to introduce external forcing
but but that roughly speaking that's
that's not easy to to generalize to
manifold uh so if you um
if you introduce a time dependence
that's somehow more intrinsic it's
independent of the coordinate so uh so
that's that's why it can be used for
those many fun generalizations
that's a great question thank you
all right um any other question
[Music]
i i was impressed by you know how you
use the the the dynamics uh to come up
with the um the the up you know the
improving the optimization of the neural
network
algorithm that was that is
very nice in some sense it was analysis
called where the monte carlo um and
there is a hamiltonian multicolored and
you know the hamiltonian monte carlo is
kind of thought of as a physics based uh
uh inspired the monte carlo sampling
method so i guess your
uh your approach is have the similar
uh yeah innovation
yeah
yeah i'm so glad you mentioned this um
um because in fact you know some of some
of the things that i didn't mention is
is something and uh you can have you
know naive monte carlo approaches like
metropolis hasting you can also have a
hamiltonian version which is in some
sense you know adding momentum uh to
accelerate the sampling algorithm and
this is something that uh that we do a
lot so so we love this kind of stuff so
so i couldn't agree more with you so so
in fact you know there there is
something called uh you know there's
there's also something called over
dental laundromat which is a stochastic
generalization uh of uh of gradient flow
or gradient descent if you will um
and uh and one can add momentum one can
one can actually have something called
kinetic energy one which is like a
momentum version uh
that that is closely related to
stochastic gradient distance with
momentum etc uh and uh that does
accelerated uh uh sampling which is
sort of like a probabilistic
generalization of optimization so
so these are some of the things that we
are very fascinated about
very nice very nice
all right
go ahead go ahead they can they can they
they they still very high dimensional uh
statistical inference problems very well
because the momentum
can improve the dimension dependence etc
very nice very nice very nice
all right sounds good is there any other
questions from audience
i don't see any uh well if that's the
case then let's thank our speaker i'm
sure um you know the the the people who
left ali they can you know come back and
watch and then um
probably they can um you know contact
you personally
and you guys
that'll be pleasant for the discussion
and
hopefully that will lead to the future
collaboration as well because that's the
ultimate goal of this episode so
thank you thank you let's thank our
speaker today
thank you
yeah
all right
all right see you
okay let me stop